right time for today's bar chart it's
the five year junk bombed rally over
that's my question today this is the
Bloomberg Global high-yield corporate
bond index from 2010. this is the price
not the yield the price not the yield up
until recently it was on track for its
fifth annual increase that's since the
series began in 2010 that's the
left-hand corner of your screen junk
bonds as measured by the Bank of America
Merrill Lynch index have risen every
year since 2008 that Year by the way
junk bonds sunk by 27 now as of today
the Bloomberg high yield index is down
by 1.6 in 2014. in December alone it's
dropped 3.6 that's the worst monthly
performance in three years more than 80
billion dollars has been wiped off the
value of junk Securities in the last
month since reaching an all-time high
see that yellow circle on July the night
the index has sunk by seven percent
average yields have moved a long way
just a space of a few months in June
Bank of America Merrill Lynch indices
show they fell to a record low of 4.92
percent average yields right now are
above seven percent the shift has been
stunning the words of James Camp he's a
portfolio manager at Eagle asset
management and he goes on to say if
history is any guide is not at all clear
that things will just snap back now one
of the reasons why we're seeing this big
shift in high yield is the movement in
the price of oil Energy company bonds
make up about 10 percent of the global
high-yield market and investors are
shunning the debt on concern that oil
prices below sixty dollars will
precipitate defaults and it's bonds that
are issued by energy companies that are
bearing the brunt of this sell-off down
12 in December that's interesting
according to Bank of America
data but don't feel too down for junk
bond investors as I said since 2010
we've been on a a long rally it's been
quite a run since the end of 2008 as I
said according to Bank of America
Merrill Lynch data since then junk bonds
have returned
143 despite weak periods back in 2011
and
2013 but has the five-year junk bond
rally come to an end we